I love being the new
turn off the TV and all of a sudden I
swelled up from the bath from the
lavender that was so good yes
yes hi I'm Holly Bailey and I'm Jonah
Howard King and this is First
Impressions for lad Bible right who
wants to go first okay let's see
if she were to meet you she'd be like
hello Jonah it's so nice to meet you
it is so nice to meet you I hope you
like all my songs it's not is it yeah
that's so good
first time knowledge okay
yeah
I don't know it's not gonna be good
um
hi okay
um I uh
oh no what's the what's this catchphrase
he's got like a um Something's Cooking
I have no idea hi I'm I'm uh really
strong and uh I'm a a businessman and an
actor and um I can do uh uh I can lift
heavy buildings and
um and I am also another word for a
pebble oh
oh
I love this lady oh my gosh um
I don't know how to
oh I can't even do it
oh see you now I I got here and I took a
bath and all of a sudden I I swelled up
from the bath from the lavender oh wait
wait was it Jennifer cooler yes
wow okay yeah nice
um
Ariel you are
so who is that
um okay
um uh
um keep on that bed that's good
um
the force uh is with you oh um
Yoda yeah okay
[Laughter]
oh hey guys I'm so excited to be here
today I love being the new
I love being the new
and her love Zendaya so much yeah
okay
[Laughter]
um
yeah
we have
um
no okay um
here we have the Lesser spotted
Gannett which can fly the guy from
National Geographic so in a way yeah
oh the the 60 miles an hour Australian
guy nope
um and uh he you're on the right track
though I don't know if do you know maybe
you don't know this guy sir I don't know
David's Attenborough no I didn't know
dang after this okay
this person is amazing
um she's a singer I love the way I love
the way the way you love
you give me that kind of something or
um
I see it I like it I want it I got it I
want it I got it I want it I got it okay
you didn't think it did it on purpose
again she's um she is
uh in the new Wicked Ariana Grande yeah
yeah okay
turn off the TV Simpson yeah
um
the wife yes yeah
what's her name Marjorie okay
hey guys it's me I am King
uh here is my lip kit I have such a
beautiful family
stormy and air are my beautiful children
I should know this and I don't know this
and Travis Scott is my baby daddy I'm
Really Gonna I'm gonna put oh how do you
not I know she's so amazing this is my
lip kit wait Travis Scott is it one of
the Kardashians married yes Kylie yes
thank you I love her
oh
[Laughter]
yeah what
[Applause]
um to me
yes okay
good okay
um
oh this is like your big celebrity crush
mine yeah
and hi guys I play the new Barbie
when we saw her in L.A remember you like
oh my God if she comes over here
Jonas literally we saw Mark
don't look at me
yeah she is cool
oh
yes
hi can I please have some hash browns
today Holly yeah
how many can you eat in one city oh my
God like is
19.
um
um Expelliarmus
Harry Potter okay
laughs
oh oh I don't know how I'm gonna do this
one
um
Jonah
oh no I haven't seen you in two years
no
um very similar to me though it's Chloe
Chloe
how'd you feel I feel upset I feel a bit
of deflated I thought I was doing really
well but she won
you both really got into it that was
great
that was fun
there was a baby llama in the desert is
this Lawrence Olivier
I don't know I think okay hang on the
big great whale swims to the shore what
on Earth yeah
actually